impossibility results in a synchronous
shared memory systems and this part of
the talk and I'm gonna discuss two
important techniques covering arguments
and valency arguments so I first wanted
to find what covering means a process P
I it said cover a register R in a
configuration see if P irate stew R
whenever P I is next allocated the step
by the scheduler and the result of that
right basically hides previous rates to
R by other processes a block right is a
sequence of consecutive steps very
different processes which the each write
to a different register previous writes
to the set of registers but other
processes are hidden when this block
right is performed so the idea of a
block right is I think best illustrated
by the the carnival game called black
Amol so this is a game where you have
little moles of pop up on a board and
you have big malice that are soft and
you have to hit the moles on the head
and the idea is you were this one
well-known strategy for doing well on
this before they the moles pop up and
then go back down again you want to hit
them before they go down again and so
one of the well-known strategies for
this is to keep your balance if you can
get two of them over two holes and so
when the moles pop up you're ready to
whack them so this is the notion if
you're covering those two holes so
that's a my favorite analogy for the
notion of it of covering B is covering a
register R it's still possible that the
old value of R was read before P i okay
yeah so what would you it just we're
saying what happens when when the
adversarial schedule or next schedule P
it will overwrite whatever is there
it'll just it's covering it now and so
it's ready to go and begin it when
something important like relevant
information information happens to get
written then the adversary can say ah
I'll get rid of that useful information
okay so that's really how the adversary
can use this so that's that's the point
okay so the goal of a covering argument
is constructed configuration which all
registers are covered and then any
execution Alfre from this configuration
c via this execution here can basically
be hidden by the block right okay so
what we have is a pair this block right
then we can have some other execution
going on after that and even if this
execution takes place since whatever
whatever information you're right is
going to be overwritten by this block
right to every register the same
execution here can take place here as
well as here so that's the the main idea
the intuition about how such arguments
go and then there's lots of different
there's lots of details so you get that
to work well so ok so let me we'll get
to that in a second yeah so all right so
okay so we want to construct this
configuration which you all are covered
and this can can use it to show that any
asynchronous algorithm using too few
registers can behave incorrect correctly
and so in fact we don't it doesn't even
matter how big the registers are it's
just the number of registers okay and
basically the construction is inductive
with the number of coverage objects
increasing as the argument progresses so
we start with nothing being covered and
then we show that one will be covered
and then we can get it configuration
with o2 etc until we have everything
being covered
so in order to illustrate this technique
I'm going to present the following
results on due to Burns and Lynch which
is that any mutual exclusion algorithm
for two or more processes uses least end
registers and in fact covering a group
algorithm or covering arguments were
first introduced in this particular
lower bound okay you know the modeling
to consider is an asynchronous shared
memory system in which every process has
a distinct ID processes communicate
through shared read/write registers of
unbounded size so I'm just emphasizing
that we only do reads and writes and
there are no faults okay so pretty basic
kind of model okay
all right so what's the mutual exclusion
problem because I promise this talk
we're gonna require no background in
distributed computing
so this problem models the situation
which processes need temporary exclusive
access to a shared resources for example
a shared printer ok we only want to
print one thing at a time I don't want
you know some of your print job and my
print job to be mixed up in the same
page not very useful ok so to get the
resource a process performs an entry
protocol ok each process has some
protocol and that's going to follow and
when a process is finished using the
resource it performs an exit protocol
and a process is said to be idle if it
doesn't have the resource and it's not
performing the and its entry or exit
protocol ok so they're sort of you sort
of four states a process can be in
either idle then it if it decides it
wants to use the resource it goes into
its entry protocol eventually we hope
that it gets the resource and then once
it's finished it goes does its exit
protocol and it becomes idle again ok
and when we have a an idle process we
were considering it to not cover any
process sorry it's not kind of reading
register ok so it basically has to have
somehow from the outside thing or
whatever other things that's doing the
the necessity for needing the resource
and then it starts doing answering
protocols so we say that idle process
isn't covering any register ok
all right now I'm neutral exclusion
algorithm consists of entry and exit
protocols for each process that satisfy
two different conditions the first is
mutual exclusion which says in any
configuration and most one process has
the resource okay so we're not both
printing at the same time and the second
is deadlock freedom which basically says
we're never in a situation where no
progress can be made
so with this more precisely this is
starting from any configuration seeing
which some process is performing its
entry protocol okay and no process has
the resource so there's something that
we want to have happen okay there is a
finite execution right processes that
are not idle and see okay so you for
idle you don't care you're not really
part of it which causes some process to
get the resource okay we're not saying
that every process is necessarily going
to have its request satisfied but just
the the system as a whole it's gonna
make progress that infinitely big basis
goes on infinitely off and then
infinitely often processes they're gonna
get resources okay it's assuming that
they once they finish the resource they
give it up okay
and we don't want to have faults because
if a process has the result with the the
resource and then crashes then nobody
else is going to get the research so
that's why we basically make more
falseness in this problem okay so what
we want to do is in order to prove the
theorem I'm going to prove two lemmas
and the first one was the following okay
it's going to be using a covering
argument it okay so it it says suppose
that alpha is a finite execution by some
process P I starting from configuration
C and P I is idle and C okay and in the
when it performs execute the execution
alpha okay let's find an execution where
it's only taking steps eventually it's
going to have the resource so suppose
this happens okay we're not saying it
will but if it this does and let's let R
be the set of reg
cheers that are covered in sea okay then
what we know is that during alpha P I
must write to some register that's not
in our okay and we're gonna prove that
like always this is a proof by
contradiction okay so suppose we're in
this situation and suppose the process P
only writes to register cenar okay now
what we're going to do so we look at
this block writes beta okay because R is
covered we can have a Performa block
right here okay and we can also these
are just rights of this product these
are these are only steps by process P I
so all the other processes okay that are
covering the P I is idle so it's not
covering anything and C and all the
other processes can still perform the
rights for this configuration as well
okay so this these two configurations
are indistinguishable to to every other
process besides process P i okay and now
let's look at the situation here well
what we can say is okay so what we can
say is that from this configuration here
by the deadlock freedom property it's
possible for some there's some processes
that are are not idle and either there's
some process that has the has the
resource or there is it's possible that
some processes can perform steps and
eventually some process has the resource
okay so that we have that here now let's
look at the situation over here so we're
have some process PJ that has the
resource over here okay
now the same execution okay they these
these steps do not involve process P I
because P I is idle and deadlock freedom
says we don't have to involve I other
processes in this okay so we can perform
exactly the same execution starting from
here as we did from here because these
are indistinguishable okay but now let's
look at what happens here we know that
process P I has the resource and here we
know that process PJ has the
source and so in this configuration
process P I and P J both have the
resource and hence we have a problem
okay we've shown that the algorithm is
incorrect questions good
okay so um the second lemon we want to
prove is the following okay but before
we do that it's this one here I've
written lemma one up on the board
because it will have to refer to it
later on okay so we say that if
configuration is quiescent if every
process is idle okay so it's you know
it's this and in fact the initial
configuration is going to be quiescent
okay so nothing is happening okay so
suppose we have a quiescent
configuration Q and then we can prove
that from any course from configuration
Q for all K between 1 and n their
executions Sigma and Delta such that if
we start in Q and perform Delta we get
that end up in a at quiescent
configuration again okay so all the
processes are idle we have the fact that
all the registers have the same value in
this configuration Q Sigma and Q Delta
so after performing Sigma and performing
Delta L crosses all the registers have
the same value okay
in configuration Q Sigma the first K
processes P 0 through Cape through PK
minus 1
I'll cover different registers and
finally these two configurations Q Sigma
and Q Delta are indistinguishable to all
the other processes PK through PN minus
1 okay so we're going to prove this
lemma
well okay but before we prove that will
prove the theorem so the theorem says
any mutual exclusion algorithm for end
processes use this at least in registers
so we know that the initial
configuration is quite quiescent let's
apply lemma 2 with K equals n so there
is a we get to an X configuration where
n minus 1 processes so end processes
cover in different registers and hence
we need at least n registers for our
algorithm ok so this is this lemma
itself is the the workhorse that we have
to do so and essentially yes they cover
key different HK yeah in particular Fred
we can get that so what we're basically
said well show that basic we'll start
from and this will be an induction and
we'll build this up and as long as K s
is less than n we can extend the
induction one more step ok so that's
really what's what's happening
okay so the proof of lemma two is by
induction on K and the base case is two
equals one
okay so so we get luck freedom there's
an execution alpha by P naught in which
P naught gets the Reiser so we're
starting with this quiescent
configuration and process P naught all
of a sudden now says I want to start
I've been the only non idle process I
would like the resource and so from that
configuration not necessarily from Q but
this one additional step we're gonna
decides what it wants to do that it
wants this so it it's the only non idle
process so eventually you can run it and
there's some execution in which p p0
gets the resource okay and by lemma 1
during this execution alpha P has to
write to some register okay
book has in in a configuration Q okay
there's nothing covered so we have to
write to something that would okay we're
starting from some configuration Q in
which nothing is covered okay
and so it's on the right to some
register so um what we're gonna do is
look at the longest priests prefix of
alpha that contains no rights okay so
there is gonna be at least one right in
the Sigma and we sorry in alpha and we
take Sigma to be the longest prefix that
contains no rights and so what we're
going to do is Sigma is going to be that
and Delta is going to be the empty
execution okay so let's see what's
happening well first of all since Cuse
is quiescent and queued and deltas the
empty execution is certainly Q Delta
screen essent now all right sisters have
the same values and these two well none
of the registers have changed here but
in fact during Sigma there weren't any
rights so none of the registers have
changed value here okay so that's still
okay
pa covers one register in Q Sigma
because we letting it run until it's
just about two right so it's covering
something when it next allocated the
step it'll right because that's we took
Sigma to be
to make that happen and here's Sigma and
Q Delta indistinguishable to all other
processes well nothing else has been
written so there's there nothing else
has happened none of the other ones have
taken steps so they have no way of
getting any information about what's
happening so as far as they're concerned
they can't see what process Pissarro is
done and so we're done okay so that's
that's the easy base case okay so for
our induction step let's let Kate be
less then this was supposed to be and
assume the claim is true for our so by
the induction hypothesis for from any
quiescent configuration QT their
executions Sigma T and delta T that
satisfied the claim okay now we know
that this is quiescent this
configuration is quiescent and these two
configurations are indistinguishable to
all other processes okay besides p 0 to
p k minus 1 so they we know that they're
they're idle in this configuration okay
so what we're going to do is consider
okay so we remember that in a QT Sigma T
so satisfying the claim okay they they
cover different registers and so let's
beta t be the block right by these
processes cops starting from this
configuration okay so they're they're
covering them we can do the block right
and now let's consider after that block
right let's let gamma T be a finite
execution by those processes that that
results in a quiescent configuration so
basically what's happening is I mean
these are the only everything else is
idle these processes do their block
rights and we're going to let one of
them by deadlock freedom one of them
will
able to go to the entries do its entry
section get the resource and then we let
it go away and then become idle and we
left another one go and eventually this
is an execution in which all of them are
idle
ok so that's what we have here with this
gamete hey we just left all the rest of
the finish up so what are you back into
acquiescence of configuration so this is
what we have here ok so we start with Q
being q1 and we apply this we have the
Delta 1 going down to quiescent and we
have this Sigma 1 beta 1 Delta Gamma 1
going to another quiescent configuration
Q 2 and from Q 2 again we have a delta 2
and Sigma 2 beta 2 gamma 2 ok so we
could do what we just did on the same on
the previous slide over and over and
over again yes could you expand again
like such a common theme must exist ok
so what we had so let me go back there
ok so we've done the blog so all the
other processes are idle and now what we
have is we have these the first King K
processes are doing a block right so
they're doing something they're not idle
ok so they might be in there I'm doing
their exit a protocol their entry
protocol and so eventually what we by
deadlock freedom we know that from this
configuration either there's something
someone one of them there's a product
there must be a process it'll eventually
get the resource ok and then we let the
product that process finish with it's a
resource and finish this exit protocol
finish the exit protocol yes ok I mean
that's in it I didn't actually put in
all the requirements but yes but I mean
exit protocol the exit part usually is
very easy like this one yeah yeah so
that's gonna happen something will will
get that process getting the resource
and then it's finished with it and then
they'll become idle ok and then by
deadlock freedom we know if there's any
other process there that it's still in
its entering protocol doing this entry
protocol will let one of those
eventually one of those has to have and
get the resource and again wheels
repeatedly will do we just do them one
at a time not letting any of the idle
processes start through entry protocol
okay and eventually they were all going
to be done okay
so we've all finished printing our bit
you know the final versions of our
papers and I hope you are going home
okay and we're not going to do a second
one okay so that's weird we're there
okay so we have this this nice setup
where we ending up with all these
circles are quiescent configurations
okay
now by the pigeonhole principle there
exists a t less than t prime such that
beta t and beta t primer block writes
the same set of K of K registers R okay
so we only we're assuming that let's say
we have I mean if we had more than n
written registers to begin with I mean
you know we have we have our theorem so
we're we're assuming that we have at
most n registers and so you know there's
a fully a finite number of registers and
we're writing to K of them so that
eventually if we have n choose K plus
one of these things two of these will
write to the same set of registers okay
so all right so now let's look at that
that see here okay the first of these
and um set sets quiescence this thing
down here there's some sort of finite
execution alpha by ki k starting from
from there such a PK has the resource in
that execution so we're just letting
that one go by itself okay now let's
look at these two configurations QT
Sigma T and Q T delta T now they're
indistinguishable to process PK and all
registers have the same values in these
two configurations that was part of our
there were some the things we got from
the induction hypothesis okay so we know
that alpha can occur starting from this
configuration as well as as the delta T
so DQ T delta T okay so it can start
there because PK is is one of the
registers
it's not one of the first K registers
it's the k plus first register okay
so alpha can occur starting from that
because these two are indistinguishable
in this process PK and since PK has the
resource after alpha starting when it
starts with Q K delta T it also has the
resource when it starts from Q k Sigma T
okay so we have that so let's see that
evening and then at the beginning of
next one okay so we have we didn't look
look at whatever the execution was it
takes us to Q T up at the top I put that
there and and now and then we have the
Sigma T there okay and okay we have this
this and then we have some additional
okay so then we have the rest of this
execution that takes us to Q T prime and
I have this Delta this thing here that
takes me to
yeah yeah okay so
yeah so I I have this additional delta-t
t-prime that goes down here and I have a
Sigma T Prime that goes over here okay
so that's the setup and we have this
execution Alf I just talked about in the
previous slide okay in which process PK
is only is the only process taking steps
okay by lemma one it's an execution in
which process PK it's eventually going
to get the resource so by lemma 1 during
alpha PK has to write to sub register
not an R okay because and configure it
in this configuration up here okay
it's the registers and are covered okay
that's what we knew okay um okay so
pinky has to cover a register not an R
and since PT is a block right to art
each register has the same value after
this block right here and after this
block right here okay
so the rest of that execution here on
here on okay this one can take place a
tip place over here it can also take
place over here because everything is
the same and it's not involving any step
it's only involving steps the first K
minus-1 processes okay okay so that's
what we have here it's only starting
okay so what we're going to do is define
Sigma so Sigma is going to be this whole
execution here it's going to go along
here come down here go all the way here
and end up here so that's my execution
Sigma okay
and what I'm gonna do for Delta yes I'm
gonna go along here go all the way along
here and follow the delta prime delta T
Prime
down here to I'm going to call that
Delta okay so one case I'm going for the
Sigma I'm going along here and for the
Delta I'm going along here okay
all right so this is the situation we're
in I just sort of focused from that part
and we have our alpha and so the
district there's this difference without
this alpha Prime and there's the little
difference at the end okay now let me
show you that all of the the
requirements of the lemma the four
points that I have down at the bottom
okay are on facts all satisfied okay Q
Delta is quiescent why well QT we were
in QT and we've had this execution delta
T Prime and that led to something that
was crescent that was part of our
induction hypothesis so that one's good
all registers have the same values in
urine here okay so why is that well we
know that all registers have the same
values here and here okay that was by
the induction hypothesis okay we knew
that QT Sigma T Prime and Q T delta T
Prime all the processes have the same
although registers have the same value
okay
and what we also know is that okay we
don't have any there's no what the right
doesn't take place hero's all the rights
that this is the block right here okay
and all the rights that took place in
here
we're overwritten by this block right
bTW because these are all only writes to
2r and BC is a block right too far so
everything that was all of the
interesting stuff that PK did has been
overwritten and we stopped that
execution we cut it off alpha at alpha
prime before it did anything else
outside okay and okay so they all have
the same they have the same values here
and here and ends here and here okay and
okay what about p0 through PK to cover K
plus 1 different registers here
well they cover any different registers
here okay and basically they cover the
registers R that was the definition of Q
T Prime
okay they also cover the same registers
R over here and PK covers some register
that's not an R ok so that's an
additional register there so there's K
plus 1 different registers that the
first k plus 1 processes cover and these
two configurations Q Sigma and Q Delta
are indistinguishable to all other
processes why well these two
configurations are indistinguishable to
the first K processes as well but the
first K processes and these
configurations here are
indistinguishable to all processes
except for a piece of K so in particular
this configure this this and this are
indistinguishable these these two
configurations are indistinguishable to
process k plus 2 up to n minus 1 so what
we have here is a proof of lemma 2 or at
least a proof of the induction step and
hence we have lemma 2 proved and as I
said earlier we have a proof of the
theorem Paul so for me to understand
clearly so for this proof of lemon to
applying lemma 1 creating intermediate
quiescent States sort of many many times
fall for all subsets like n choose K or
whatever we're doing this kind of thing
yes each of those things is you're just
doing one step of lemma 2 and then you
are reapplying level one over and over
again you still haven't gotten that k
plus first thing they tell you yes yeah
so the important thing is we had to use
the pigeonhole principle we needed the
same set R to be to be in down here okay
this is the the set of things that were
covered here oh sorry we look at this
point here we had our
are covered here and we want to go to a
later place where those same are covered
so that when we whatever we do going in
delta T we can also move it over into T
Prime and so that's sort of what's
happening so we do this many many times
we apply we apply this yeah we apply the
the the induction step of lemma to
multiple times and in each one in any
one of them we could apply lemma one but
it's only going to be useful when we
have the T and T prime so that they're
covering the same set of registers very
long so this is okay so this is a space
lower bound okay that's all we're
carrying about the number of registers
I'm this is not saying anything at all
about time okay and in fact covering
arguments typically are just used for
space little bounce there are some
situations where you can do you can have
it space and time and spread some funny
wing is good so might be that there is
some algorithm which works as a spider
algorithm that's only under the ten
steps and the first problem is that if
you're doing of the ten steps plus one
we have to guarantee mutual exclusion
and bite we know that a lemma one we're
gonna by lemma one we're going to get
this kind of thing okay and the one of
the things that's important about mutual
exclusion is is a long live problem okay
weeks we expect that the printer isn't
gonna die and that people are always
going to have papers that they want
print okay so if you're gonna just if
you're gonna restrict it to say well
we're looking at mutual exclusion where
each process is going to access what
wants to get the resource only once
again you might be able to have a more
efficient algorithm but that's not the
case here okay so we're looking at this
long live problem that we're yeah once
we use to process it's it's got the
resource and become idle again we can
use it again and again and again and so
it's it's really crucial for this
particular result
other questions so this is one of the
easier covering arguments but it's also
a classic it's the kind of thing that
you would see and then in a standard
internet free course okay
No okay so that's the the end of the
claim and now I'm going to so if you've
got a little lost at the end even so
we're gonna switch completely to a
different problem using a completely
different technique okay so what I want
to now do is talk about blmc argument so
this is a completely different thing and
it's where we're gonna show isn't a
possibility results okay and the problem
we're going to consider is consensus so
consensus is racial exclusion and
consensus leader election those who are
sort of mean some of the major building
blocks in for distributed algorithms and
we study them over and over again
because we have so many different models
and it really helps us under there so
fundamental it helps us understand the
distinctions between the models okay
it's not that I really care about
consensus so much but it's just a very
nice problem to work with okay so here's
the sort of high-level diagrammatic view
of consensus okay so each process has an
input and what we want to do is have all
the non-nil faulty processes agree on
the same output and that output has to
be one of the impulses
okay so that's this is a standard test
ended picture for that okay so more
formally each process P I has the
private input value VI and each non
faulty process has to output a value
after taking a finite number of steps so
either it crashes or it has to output a
value and these values have to satisfy
two different two additional properties
agreement which is that all output
values are the same okay if they don't
have to be the same it's pretty easy and
validity the output value of each is the
input value of some process again if we
don't have validity but you just say
alright everybody decides zero always
and it's done interesting okay so I mean
for the agreement we could just say
everybody should you know take your own
input value and output it and then again
it's not interesting so this is the
consensus problem okay
all right so um no problems with that
okay so now I want to talk about valency
arguments and valency arguments were
first introduced in in order to prove
the impossibility of solving consensus
in a synchronous models and so I'll
start by giving the the definitions a
little bit of the background for this so
a configuration C is said to be vu
navale n't if all executions starting
from C open V okay so you're gonna feel
it means there's only one possible
output MV and we put the V in front of
it to say that's the only possible
output and we say it's bi valent if
there are two executions starting from C
they don't put different values in
particular that's a zero on one I mean
here there presumably would be different
processes opening that and that's not
going to happen I mean so there's some
execution here where yeah you know the
value 0 so put it in if one process
outputs a zero that if it's correct
consensus algorithm any other uh product
it has to be zero and similarly here so
in particular let's see so after about
some value V has been output then every
configuration is V Vale and Fiona
valence no and every other process is
going to out sum up with something has
to open me
okay so the result that we want to prove
is that there's no deterministic
algorithm to solve consensus among two
or more processes in an asynchronous
system and this theorem was first proved
by Fisher Lynch and Patterson in the
early 80s okay and this results is often
referred to as FLP and their honor okay
then over the related for the subsequent
years number of different groups of
authors presented basically modify or
adapted this algorithm is proof two
different models and in particular
various shared memory models and I'm the
the proof of the proof I'm going to do
is in the following model it's au
synchronous shared memory processes
communicate using readwrite registers
and every process is a distinct ID and
at most n minus 1 processes can crash ok
so we're gonna do that and that happens
to be a little bit easy to the FL the
original algorithm by Fisher Lucien
Patterson which was done in an
asynchronous message passing model it
has a few additional subtleties that
we're not going to have to deal with
here ok so what's the idea is the lower
bound are so this impossibility result
basically assisted and that was the idea
is that an adversary is gonna be able to
create an infinitely long execution and
which Noah value is output that's and
which would contradict the fact that it
solves consensus ok so we're gonna have
to improve two lemmas and and then you
combine them to prove the theorem ok so
the first one was pretty easy and in
fact it really doesn't depend on the
model of computation we're working with
any any asynchronous model - ok so every
consensus algorithm has a bivalent
initial configuration in fact it works
for consent for synchronous models as
well ok so we're gonna do a proof by
contradiction
and so well first we'll assume that all
initial configurations are you know
falen's and we're going to look at
focusing on some of the initial
configurations so let's let C 0 be the
initial configuration where every
process has input 0 and let's let C and
B the initial configuration where every
process has input 1 and C 1 is a
configuration where process 0 is input 1
and all the rest of input 0 etc okay so
that's a formally defined there okay
so bite validity okay we know that C 0
is 0 unit falen's and C 1 C n is 1
univille and the Livity says that you
have to output some input value ok and
since all the inputs are 0 starting from
C 0 and they have to output 0 and
similarly from CN they all have to
output 1 ok so what that tells us if we
look along this sequence there must
exist some eye such that CI is 0 you
navale n't and the next one CI I plus 1
is 1 unit field we have to switch from
remember all of these are unit are you
navale n't there either 0 you know
feelin tour 1 unit because those are the
only inputs
ok so somehow someplace we have we have
a bunch of reds and somehow at some
point is going to switch to blue and
we're going to look at the place where
that these two consecutive input
configurations different okay so now
let's consider any execution so so in
what do we know about CI and C is 1 well
the only difference this process piece
of I which has input value 0 in
configuration CI and has input value 1
CI plus 1 ok now the ideas it
if this process P I crashes before
taking any steps other process can't
tell ok so you know all other processes
CIN CIN are indistinguishable and if we
look at any execution alpha starting
from CI
which doesn't involve a step by process
P I I need to process P I crashes before
taking any steps the other processes
can't tell there's no way they can tell
the difference between those two ok
because it's only
input for process P I is only stored
locally okay so so if we look at alpha
starting from CI it has if the other
processes have to output zero when we
take that same execution starting from
CI plus one
they're gonna have to output zero
because of indistinguishability but that
violates the assumption that CI plus 1
is 1 in avilés
okay so that's a fairly easy example of
a valency okay so the the next lemma
says that from every by violent
configuration there's a step that leads
to another bivalent configure or to a
Bible and configuration okay and okay so
now when we have this what we know is
that okay so then we can prove the
theorem so there's no deterministic
algorithm census among yeah so this
implies that there's an infinite
execution consisting only of five
eylandt configurations which violates
wheat-free termination okay why well the
initial configure our twith an initial
configuration that's bivalent and we
know that exists by Emmel one okay by
lemma two from that initial bivalent
configuration we can get to another
bivalent configuration from that one
making it to another one okay and we can
get to it if there's an infinite
sequence of these notice that no process
is output because once a process is
output a value the configuration is Univ
eylandt okay so we have an infinite
execution and that violates wheat-free
termination so it remains to prove lemma
two so yeah so what we have we're this
configuration and there I mean if
they're two processes P Zero can take
the next step or p1 can take the next
step it just chooses yeah so if we're
dealing since we're trying to construct
a bad execution the adversary the
adversarial scheduler is gonna schedule
this process then that one
and so we can we can get that yeah we
distributed computing this really nice
because we have the strong adversaries
it lets us do all sorts of good things
and makes it my life and I really lower
bound proof or maybe I convince you that
there's these are pretty and fun okay so
that's it this is what we want to just
prove lemma two okay so again to obtain
account contradiction suppose there's a
violent configuration see that all such
that all steps lead to Univ a land
configurations okay so here we have this
can this bivalent configuration see and
there there lots of generality let's
suppose the next step I process p 0
results in a at 0 unifying configuration
c 0 and the next step s1 by process p1
results no 1 univille and configuration
c1 ok without loss of generality there
was remaining things ok now then I'm
going to proof by cases ok and we're
going to get a contradiction in this
case so first of all let's suppose that
steps let's look at step 0 and step 1 by
process p 0 and P 1 and suppose they
access different registers ok well what
happens let's see what happens when we
do s 0 and then s 1 or do s 1 and a 0 ok
just do them two opposite orders well in
fact since those are two different
registers the results are gonna be
exactly the same we end up in exactly
the same configuration each processes
can each of p0 and p1 are gonna have the
same states cuz they're working on
different processes they don't interfere
with work on different registers so they
don't interfere with one another and if
they're writing to them their different
ones and so they're not going to
overwrite or interfere with them as well
so the values of all the registers are
gonna be the same here ok so now let's
look at an execution that comes this way
okay well because this is 0 Univ Eiland
any this execution is gonna have to
decide 0 but if it comes down here it's
going to have to decide 1 but the
processes can't distinguish between
these two and
so this is impossible okay good all
right suppose that s1 and so the steps
s0 and s1 or reads of the same register
okay so we we've dealt with the case
when they're accessing different things
and there's no good access anything one
so again we're going to get the same
situation if you read first and I read
or the other way around it doesn't
matter we're we don't change anything
and we're going to get to the same
configuration we're gonna have exactly
the same problem so this can't happen
okay so the third case is that they're
both access to the same register and at
least one of them is gonna right so
let's just say with a loss of generality
s1 writes okay it could be the ness 0
also writes I don't care but it okay it
doesn't really matter
okay so let's look at what happens okay
so let's look at these this
configuration at this configuration c1
we get there and then the configuration
c2 when process p 0 takes a step and
then process p1 takes in step okay now
what do we know about that well as far
as process p1 is concerned these two
configurations are indistinguishable
because all it knows is it did it's
right okay it got back into knowledge
min so it's fine and what about what do
we know about the the value of the
registers well if it might be the
process p 0 red and so it doesn't matter
or it might be that it wrote something
that registered but then process p1 over
wrote in step s1 so whatever it is here
and here that register is gonna have the
same value okay so if we have this
execution from here that decides 1 okay
this is one univille and so the
execution by process p1 from here is got
to decide one he keeps on going until it
decides we can also perform that same
execution from here and it has to side
one because it's indistinguishable to
process p1 okay but that violates the
the fact this is the easier you know
valent configuration okay so in all the
cases we've shown given a
with contradictory what's happening pull
so are you so you get to assume that an
LP was the only one I can I mean I'm in
the adversarial scheduler and I can do
that remember I mean so the the thing
that I'm doing here is I'm allowing it
up to n minus one processes crash so
it's okay and this is wait free
termination and so as long as you know
if it keeps on getting steps it's gonna
have to eventually decide or output a
value even the official inch in
Patterson that's where some of the
things have baby you can actually get
the same result if you in one process
only one process crashes and and then
you have and you have to worry but some
fairness conditions to stuff so there
are lots of other things you can make
this result stronger but I want you to
give you the main idea okay so we've now
proved that we have no dis termina stick
algorithm okay in an asynchronous shared
memory model no wait for you like
consensus algorithm yeah there were
three cases what about the three cases
they access different registers they
read the same register and at least one
of them writes to that register yeah it
doesn't matter which one it is yeah
zeros right yeah it doesn't matter
whether it's a writer or a read it
doesn't matter because what happens is
whatever this right is the results of
the value in that register it's the same
register is now going to be fixed by the
right to to that register by process p1
questions okay
now consensus can be solved in an
asynchronous shared memory system using
a single compare-and-swap object okay
either basically it starts with the
bottom the first process does a compare
and swap with bottom every process tries
to do compare and swap with bottom and
it's input value and all of that that
one gets back at bottom and says okay
I'll decide my own value and everybody
else gets back that value so we can do
this for any number and so what this
basically said tells us is a synchronous
shared memory system with only registers
are less powerful than a synchronous
shared memory systems with compare and
swap objects and registers and in fact
real real systems real distributed
systems all have compare and swap
objects and and most of the new
interesting algorithms actually use
compare and swap but for the purposes of
the talk and just to keep the model
simple I've sort of ignored all of them
and and we've just focused on read
registers but there's a lot and the
valency arguments can be adapted to not
to compare and swap objects because
obviously you can do that but other
kinds of objects you can show can do
consensus for some number of processes
but not more so for example if you just
have something called a test and set
object it can solve consensus among two
processes but not three etc okay a queue
if you have a queue it can solve
consensus among two processes but not
three and so similar kinds of valency
arguments can be confused there okay now
consensus also can be solved using
randomization so in consents this is
something we want to do it's really
important for distributed computing so
there are lots of ways around it and
neither either using stronger shared
memory primitives or using randomization
or good ways to deal with that the
statement of the problem is a little bit
different so we still have agreement and
validity but instead of weight free
termination we have something called
randomized weight free termination so we
know on faulty process outputs of value
after taking expected finite number of
steps so infinite executions are
possible but happily with zero
probability okay
so now there is an algorithm which
solves randomized consensus among men
process and so when she's expected to
him numbers that's taken by all
processes so we're counting all the
steps that are taken is o of N squared
okay so this is a step complexity of
complexity it wasn't that long ago ten
years ago that a TM sensor parallel
proved that any algorithm that solves a
randomized consensus among and processes
uses Omega N squared expected has
expected total step complexity you may
have n squared okay so they prove that
you use this a valency argument but I'm
much much much more complicated valency
argument and it's not just you know
valent and bivalent but there are other
kinds of things that you have to other
kinds of valence e's come into it and
one has to worry about the probabilities
of things happening this algorithm here
which matches their lower bound in fact
it's a very subtle algorithm and
sentence was proved in the same paper so
there are there are there algorithms
that are less efficient but this is the
most efficient one in terms of step
complexity yeah I mean yeah I think I
I'm remembering correctly I think they
were even was an asynchronous random
myself in them as well
yeah this paper here so it's not that
the I mean there are lots of algorithms
that are easy to randomized that just
use registers and that I would teach in
and under you know you know beginning
theory of distributed computing but I
would not teach that but I just wanted
to say that that's tight okay so the
people that's that's well known they
were also randomized algorithms for
consensus and among in processes used in
registers that other one was much space
complexity was was bad and in fact it
was
a couple of years ago in stock my PhD
students Jimmy proved that any
randomized algorithm consensus among n
processes must use at least n minus 1
registers so this is almost tight I mean
it was very very close and this in fact
and this year at Potsie we presented a
an improvement to this so this is the
result by Jimmy in 2016 is a valence
it's a combination of covering arguments
in valency it's yeah it has some very
nice definitions it's certainly much
more complicated than what I presented
it's a it anyhow so it was there were
some really lovely ideas for that and we
were able use approach we were able to
get rid of the additional one that was
not the main point of the paper but it
would occur all the fact that we can
actually show that in such a tight space
complexity one of the things that's
interesting the the previous best lower
bound for space complexity of randomized
consensus was a make of square root of n
and that was something I did with
Moore's Herlihy and near shiv feet about
I think more than 25 years ago and there
had been no progress and I mean
essentially no progress in the mean time
for that general problem B the only
thing that's but still opening this is
that for that result it applied not only
to registers but also when the model
included some additional things like it
could include a test and set registers
objects and a few other kinds of things
like that swap not compare and swap
obviously but it and but this this this
lower bound all the applies for
registers as does this okay and so then
still open where the space lower bound
when we have more powerful objects can
be extended obviously with the
comparison like with the
compare-and-swap but one one object and
that's easy me out there that I gave you
before so that's an that's an open
question that
still exist okay question no question
yes I think I might just might have
missed it the order in squared algorithm
uses in registers every no no no listen
things if they're there they're out
there algorithms that are much easier
there yeah um yeah I don't know I don't
think people have actually thought about
the time-space trade-offs between those
yeah I mean there are the the actually
this actual okay this lower bound here
there's an improvement that says that
there's a variant that says every
process has to perform Omega vens steps
so there's a strengthening of that just
not overall but in fact every process
has to have perform a making event step
so they had that later on but in terms
of the speed the trade-off between space
and and time there hasn't been anything
that's been considered so yeah that
would be your I mean the techniques are
fairly different so I'm not I yeah I'm
not sure it would be I wouldn't see an
easy way of combining them to give an
eternity rate off I want to just mention
the last couple of minutes
one additional problem called casein
agreements it's a generalization of
consensus so this is exactly the same in
that each process is a private input
value VI and each non faulty process has
to output a value after taking finite
number of steps validity the output
value of each process is the input value
of some process which is exactly the
same the difference is that at most K
different values are output so the case
K equals one is consensus the case K
equals two is the situation where you're
in this gourmet restaurant and the chef
will only make two different dishes for
the table and everybody the table has to
agree on which main courses that are
going to order okay so that would be the
case of K equals 2 so this anyhow this
how this problem also has a long history
of being studied theory of distributed
computing literature
and there are random lights out so again
it's a generalization of consensus and
so there's not going to be any
deterministic algorithm eyes day
algorithms for case that agreement among
yin processes that use n minus k plus 1
registers and the actual results the
main result that we proved in the Ponzi
paper that I was referring to a couple
of slides ago was that any randomized
algorithm case that agreement among ends
processes must use n minus 1 over k plus
1 registers so there's still a gap from
n minus K to n minus 1 over K so that's
a big gap what was nice is that prior to
this the best lower bound was to okay so
there's still a big gap and there are
lots of there are lots of other
fundamental problems I have a book about
a graph Becky I have a lower back and
all this is organized by technique so
each chapter is a different technique
and and there isn't the only thing was
that we didn't put in any communication
who likes new results there and
presumably in the next version we will
anyhow there any other questions
[Applause]